no Jay Simpson will soon be free from
prison the former football star showed
jubilation and relief yesterday after
convincing a nevada parole board that he
deserves to be released Simpson has
served almost nine years of a 33 year
sentence for a botched armed robbery in
Las Vegas his defenders say the sentence
was payback for his acquittal on murder
charges more than two decades ago John
Blackstone is at the Lovelock
Correctional Center in western Nevada
where Simpson will remain until at least
October 1st John good morning good
morning well the OJ we saw here was the
OJ we knew contrite defensive and
perhaps even charismatic the hearing
lasted more than an hour and the parole
board reached a unanimous decision in
less than 30 minutes mr. Simpson I do
vote to grant parole when eligible and
that will conclude this hearing thank
you Oh Jay Simpson was visibly relieved
Thursday after a Nevada parole board
granted his release I've done my time
you know I've done it as well I think
the former football star spent much of
his hearing painting himself as a
straight shooter and a family man still
when it came to the 2007 botched robbery
that landed him in jail the next year
Simpson apologized but didn't hesitate
to defend himself
it was my property I would never steal
from anybody and I would never ever pull
a weapon on anybody
I've basically has spent a conflict-free
life what about the abuse inflicted on
my sister Tania Brown's sister is Nicole
Brown Simpson who was stabbed to death
in 1994 along with friend Ron Goldman
Simpson was acquitted of the double
murder there are many many many people
out there who believe he didn't kill
Nicole and Ron but the truth of the
matter is is that he abused my sister
and we have her Diaries to prove that we
have the battered face to prove that
that's not a conflict-free life at the
hearing Simpson received support from
Bruce Froemming one of his robbery
victims this is a good man he made a
mistake and if he called me tomorrow and
said Bruce I'm getting out will you pick
me up Arnel Simpson also testified on
her father's behalf he truly is
remorseful and we just want him to come
home so that we can move forward are you
humbled by this incarceration oj may be
free but tom lange lead investigator in
the 1994 murder case doesn't think this
will be the last we see of the former
pro athlete nothing is gonna stop them
from getting in front of the camera
again his personality just that's him
he's very nice assisting Simpson says he
would like to go back to Florida where
he lived before he was warned however
that even the slightest parole violation
could land him right back here
Jeff John Blackstone thank you very much